Donald Trump pleaded not guilty to 34
counts of falsifying business records in
the first degree in a New York courtroom
yesterday and we'll get to the
consequences the questions raised by the
case but let's start with the charges
now each count has to do with payments
to former Trump lawyer Michael Cohen
who's already served prison time for
paying hush money for the president to
form our adult film actress Stormy
Daniels and that is probably the best
known case a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars was repaid to Mr Kern after he
paid Miss Daniels to stay quiet about
her alleged sexual encounter with Trump
back in 2006. Mr Trump denies he slept
with Daniels but he has acknowledged
paying Cohen the money another payment
thirty thousand dollars was made through
Ami American Media Inc the corporate
parent of the Tabloid newspaper National
Enquirer that was to buy The Silence of
a former Trump Tower doorman who is
claiming apparently falsely that Trump
fathered a child out of wedlock and
prosecutors also claimed that Ami paid
Playboy model Karen McDougall a hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in exchange
for her agreement not to speak out about
the alleged affair with Trump in 2006.
and district attorney Alvin Bragg
described this practice as a catch and
kill scheme to boost Trump's electoral
prospects this involves identifying
negative information buying that
information through means like hush
money and then suppressing it now all of
that might sound familiar because we
have heard a lot of it before but
usually these would be classed as
misdemeanors falsifying business records
rather than felonies but they're being
charged as felonies because the New York
prosecutor wants to prove the records
were falsified with an intent to commit
Aid or conceal another crime in this
case the D.A says the crime was attempts
to violate state and federal election
laws each count carries a maximum
penalty of four years in prison but even
if Trump is found guilty many legal
experts thinks it's unlikely he would
serve prison time and the case isn't
expected to go into trial until next
year so it could be well into the 2024
presidential campaign before we have a
conclusion